sorride benvenuti il nuovissimo video
era da tantissimo tempo che volevo farlo
finalmente lo sto per fare quindi ecco a
voi il mio primo video è veramente
allucinante che in tre anni di canale
non ho mai fatto un bid ask vergogna
allora in questi giorni vi ho chiesto di
inviarvi dei messaggi su director delle
mail con le vostre domande perché
appunto volevo coinvolgervi
ulteriormente in questo video ask e
quindi mi avete inviato un sacco di
domande che io purtroppo dovuto
selezionare quindi se non trovate la
vostra domanda mi dispiace ma eravate
veramente tantissimi video selezionato
diciamo quelle un po più particolari che
mi faceva piacere condividere con voi
più avanti magari quelle che ho avanzato
diciamo le utilizzerò per magari un
secondo video ask anche un subito con la
prima domanda lei la più gettonata ve la
fate spessissimo e quindi e arrivato il
momento di dare una risposta a questa
fatidica domanda cosa ti ha spinto ad
aprire un canale youtube
allora diciamo che il canale youtube
l'ho aperto un po dopo il mio percorso
all'interno del mondo del web è iniziato
con facebook infatti coperto questa
pagina facebook essenzialmente per
cantare pubblicare cover
poi però ho visto insomma che tante
tante ragazze e tanti ragazzi
pubblicavano video divertenti e visto
che mi hanno sempre detto i miei amici e
ora persone mi conoscono bene che sono
una buffone vi piace far ridere
eccetera eccetera ho detto ma proviamo a
fare questa cosa ma non avevo
assolutamente idea di quello che sarebbe
successo dopo la prossima domanda è
quando hai caricato il tuo primo video
cosa hai provato
cosa ti aspettavi allora quando caricato
il mio primo video avevo una paura
allucinante
perché comunque era la prima volta che
mi esponevo al giudizio di così tante
persone quindi sicuramente ero presa
malissimo e non mi aspettavo dunque la
c'è l'unica cosa che speravo era di non
essere massacrata di commenti negativi
quindi ero lì ogni volta che arriva un
commento
tutta e ansia perché avevo paura poi col
tempo chiaramente ci ha fatto
l'abitudine diciamo qual è stato il tuo
primo video allora il mio primo video
c'è anche se andato proprio sulla mia
pagina facebook e scorrete in basso
troverete il primo video che 23 cantanti
in tre minuti
allora fin da quando sono piccolo faccio
imitazioni di cantanti o di personaggio
eccetera eccetera
quindi ho pensato di far appunto un
video dove nyt a voi i cantanti che mi
piacciono di più che stimo di più e che
mi venivano anche meglio
e questo video ha avuto un successo
allucinante dopo quel video dopo il
successo di quel video ne ho pubblicato
un secondo infatti quando mi chiedono
qual è stato il tuo primo video mi
confondo sempre tra questi due perché
sono stati pubblicati vicino quindi è
una tripla di stanza e hanno avuto un
successo allucinante e sono
completamente diversi perché un'ora 23
cantanti in tre minuti
l'altro era una parodia diciamo delle
ragazze che fanno tutte le salutiste e
pubblica alle foto su instagram
dell'innse a latina e poi si mangiano la
carbonara e lascia all'insalata al cane
quindi quello è stato mio primo video
diciamo comico e niente ho iniziato così
fino a qualche anno fa ti saresti
aspettato tutto questo successo allora
come vi ho già anticipato prima no cioè
proprio non avevo idea di quello che
sarebbe successo dopo
all'inizio ero appunto felicissima per
questo botto diciamo che ho fatto però
non mi aspettavo sicuramente e che
sarebbe poi andato tutto così
in crescendo diciamo cioè facile magari
fare un video con milioni di più è
difficile mantenere una costante di
video che piacciono al pubblico e
appunto far crescere questa famiglia
diciamo di follower di persone che ti
seguono quindi non mi aspettavo
assolutamente che succedesse tutto
questo quando avevi quindici anni qual
era la cosa che appassionava di più
allora sicuramente ero tra appassionata
di musica e colleziona voci di
collezionavo cassette e soprattutto
adoravo cantare e cantavo sempre sempre
a scuola nei miei compagni mi odiavano
perché no in gita in mettiamo ai posti
in fondo iniziamo il concerto dopo tipo
1 ora 2 ore di pullman volevano buttarmi
fuori prima dei 15 anni la mia passione
era la danza invece ho fatto dieci anni
danza classica poi ho lasciato penso
proprio intorno ai 14 anni
spesso mi hanno chiesto ma perché hai
lasciato danza per chi fa danza è un
trauma da abbandonare insomma diciamo
che ho fatto questa scelta perché ho
capito che non era la mia la mia strada
è una parte bellissima della mia vita è
sicuramente è stata una mia passione lo
è tuttora perché piace un sacco andare a
vedere i balletti
però diciamo che il canto e la
recitazione sono un po più in alto per
me che scuola superiore frequentato
allora dopo le medie ho seguito la mia
migliore amica che si è scritto lo
scientifico quindi stupidamente non fate
questo errore mi sono iscritto allo
scientifico per stare insieme la mia
migliore amica perché avevo strappa ura
del mondo del liceo non fate questa
regata perché dopo un anno e mezzo e
dopo tanti 3 e 4 il latino e matematica
e qualsiasi materia scientifica
ho deciso di cambiare perché se non mi
avrebbero bocciato quindi sono passata
al liceo linguistico che sicuramente
faceva più per me
vogliamo spagnolo che va bene era
vantaggiato perché mio papà spagnolo
quindi era un passo avanti francese e
inglese
e infatti mi sono diplomata con il
massimo dei voti come una vera secchiona
quindi un consiglio per tutti voi mi
raccomando scegliete la scuola adatta a
voi non vi fate condizionare dagli amici
perché poi prima o poi insomma i nodi
vengono al pettine ecco qual era la sua
materia preferita
allora io ho sempre amato le materie
umanistiche tranne storia non mi è mai
piaciuto particolarmente storia e amavo
filosofia amavo letteratura ma italiano
letteratura inglese francese e spagnola
erano proprio top per me è anche storia
dell'arte mi piaceva un sacco
allora questa domanda è molto bella
infatti una di quelle che mi ha colpito
di più cos'è per te la musica allora per
rispondere a questa domanda vi vorrei
raccontare un piccolo aneddoto
non so perché però quando ero piccolina
tipo elementari tra con tra i compagni
ci si facevano queste domande che ai
tempi che sono fossero cretine però
effettivamente è invece erano abbastanza
profonde
una di queste domande era ma se tu
dovessi scegliere preferirei un mondo
senza colori o senza musica
allora vi ricordo che le mie compagne
era sempre lì che stavano ore a pensare
e se erano indecisi
io invece espone roma mamma ma ragazzo
ma stiamo scherzando ma senza colori
tutta la vita io no ma non posso
rinunciare alla musica
quindi questo per farvi capire quanto la
musica sempre stata importante per me mi
ha accompagnato durante tutta la vita
dei momenti belli nei momenti brutti c'è
sempre stata e sempre stato mio fianco e
per me come se fosse una migliore amica
diciamo astratta vorresti un animale ne
hai mai avuto uno allora sì da piccolo
avevo un gatto miti che purtroppo non
c'è più è però il mio sogno è avere un
cane mia mamma mi ha preso il gatto
perché pensava giustamente che fosse
meno
impegnativo e visto che ero piccola
anche se dice oh mamma lo porto io foro
proprio fuori sapeva già che comunque
non ero in grado di averne pura e
occuparmene come bisognerebbe e quindi
mi è rimasto il pallino fin
dall'infanzia di prendere un cane e
prima o poi prenderò un cane sto
cercando di convincere salvo che non è
molto dell'idea
com'è nata la tua passione per la
comicità allora questa anche una
bellissima domanda me la fate spesso è
la risposta è non lo so cioè io penso di
essere nata così con insomma questa vena
comica e e questa voglia di fare la
buffone di far ridere gli altri di base
da piccola
già da piccolo facevo le imitazioni non
dei cantanti non dei personaggi famosi
dei compagni di classe e degli
insegnanti infatti il video che ho fatto
degli insegnanti le tipologie di
professori che ha avuto sempre successo
in realtà è basato su fatti realmente
accaduti perché la maggior parte di
quelle tipologie erano rappresentavano
dei miei professori reali di che segno
zodiacale 6
allora io sono nata il 16 luglio quindi
sono del cancro ma ho scoperto da poco
ero convinta di essere ascendente cancro
è invece no sono ascendente leone
infatti leggendo appunto le
caratteristiche dei vari segni io sono
fissato mi piacciono queste cose
dell'astrologia e ho scoperto che sono
esattamente il connubio tra le
caratteristiche del cancro e del del
leone quindi per esempio le
caratteristiche del cancro in cui mi
ritrovo sono il fatto di essere molto
legata al passato e alla famiglia
questo è vero è invece del leone il
fatto di essere molto insomma la tenace
e combattiva
per quanto riguarda il raggiungimento
dei propri obiettivi che lavoro ore di
fare da piccola
alle elementari alle medie e al liceo
allora alle elementari
volevo fare la parrucchiera infatti uno
dei primi giorni di scuola avevano
chiesto di rappresentare disegnare
insomma il lavoro che avremmo voluto a
fare da grande tre grandi e io ho
disegnato il mio bellissimo salone di
bellezza
del quale era la proprietaria
chiaramente e io mi sono rappresentata
bionda platino quindi che l'ho già molto
come sono briand elementari e invece
alle medie liceo già iniziamo a capire
che mi sarebbe piaciuto fare musica mi
sarebbe piaciuto recitare
insomma intraprenderla la strada del del
mondo dello spettacolo quindi dal
parrucchiere poi ci sono solo più andata
e non ho più sognato insomma di aprirmi
mio salone che non mi avresti voluto
avere ti piace il tuo nome
allora il nome marina mi piace però non
me lo sento proprio tanto cucito addosso
avrei preferito un nome un po più strong
proprio deciso e in particolare quando
sono nata e c'è stata una divisione in
famiglia perché mia sarebbero a
chiamarmi francesca mia mamma mai a
quella y e mio padre carmen perché il 16
luglio il giorno della mia nascita in
spagna è il giorno della attività della
virgen del carmen
quindi quando sono nata mia madre mi
aveva messo il braccialettino già
costretto il nome mai a bola y mio padre
quando arrivate in ospedale tono
assolutamente non vi piace maya e quindi
doveva trovare una via di mezzo tra
carmen che a quanto pare a mia mamma non
piaceva più che altro perché essendo
meta italiana metà spagnola quello era
un nome molto da di spagna mar italia un
po meno quindi non era molto convinta
l'ho trovato via di mezzo che era marina
però se dovessi scegliere carme
sinceramente non mi non mi dispiacerebbe
e anche il mio secondo nome che è aurora
che anche quello molto romantico molto
poetico però mi piace magari chiamerò
misure così marina è il tuo vero nome
allora il mio vero nome marina senza y e
quando dovevo scegliere insomma un nome
un nome d'arte un nome da utilizzare
insomma per il mio per il mio canale ho
pensato marina con la y per renderlo
diciamo un po diverso anche se in minima
parte dal mio nome originale perché
stravolgere completamente inventarmi un
altro nome non mio mi faceva impazzire
come the alla fine mi chiamo marina e
volevo però distinguere un minimo la
marina persona la marina personaggio
anche se in realtà
ovviamente siamo la stessa cosa però era
giusto così in ospizio hai mai pensato
di lasciare youtube il mondo dei social
perché non eri dell'umore giusto o
semplicemente perché volevi staccare un
po allora come tutte le persone in
questi anni ho avuto delle giornate no
dei momenti in cui non avevo tutta
questa voglia di fare video di essere
felice contento cioè non è che non
volevo che proprio non ero in quell
umore in quel modo lì cosa è successo
che all'inizio in quei giorni smettevo
di fare video quindi facevo un po pausa
poi ho capito che col tempo se facevo
star bene gli altri quindi se facevo
ridere gli altri automaticamente stavo
bene anche io quindi in quei momenti in
cui ero un po triste facendo video e
leggendo i vostri commenti ricevendo
tutto il vostro affetto o soltanto
vedendo che voi lì magari avanti una
brutta giornata automaticamente guardato
il video stavate meglio mi faceva stare
automaticamente bene quindi è stata una
roba come terapeutica e sono riuscita a
superare diciamo questa paura di fare
video quando sono un po giù perché so
che quello che mi date voi di ritorno è
praticamente la cura la medicina
il viaggio che sogni da tanto allora uno
dei miei sogni è sicuramente andare a
new york non ci sono mai stata
ho viaggiato abbastanza nella mia vita
però diciamo che l'america non l'ho mai
visitata quindi sicuramente new york e
la california è anche un sacco vi
piacerebbe visitare la
a latina cuba in particolare l'avana è
uno dei miei sogni
e insomma ho un po di viaggi che vorrei
pianificare prossimamente
cosa provi quando ti fermano per strada
e ti chiedono una foto o quando si
scrivono messaggi carini su direct
allora quello che che provo è difficile
da spiegare a parole perché come dico
sempre cioè e proprio come se fosse una
famiglia quindi quando ricevo dei
messaggi super carini
a volte mi sento quasi che non me li
merito non so come dire perché non
faccio niente di vinto il premio nobel
per la pace cioè faccio dei video
simpatici carini però non so come dire
non mi spiego tutto questo questo vostro
attaccamento nei confronti che è una
roba bellissima pro volte appunto paura
di come non credo di meritarmelo vi
faccio queste queste paranoie qua e
quando vi fermate per stata è bellissimo
perché insomma è lì che ready proprio
veramente il così dice l'affetto dei fan
perché il messaggio bellissimo mi fa un
sacco piacere però quando vedi una
persona che ti correggo un incontro che
abbraccia i quali si mette a piangere
liberamente che veramente capisci che
insomma sta succedendo qualcosa di bello
siamo arrivati all'ultima domanda l'ho
lasciata per ultima perché forse anzi
sicuramente è la più importante di tutte
cosa pensi delle persone che ti seguono
e cosa siamo per te allora sembra
scontato sembra banale ma siete a tutti
gli effetti ormai la mia famiglia
siete la cosa più bella che mi sia
successa per adesso quindi sicuramente
devo tutto questo voi perché siete voi
il motore insomma del personaggio marino
comunque di tutto questo percorso che
stiamo facendo insieme e spesso mi
dicono perché fai così tante storie
la risposta è perché mi piace
coinvolgervi durante tutta la giornata
della mia quotidianità e per chi appunto
di reputo proprio come degli amici e
come nei gruppi workshop in cui si
mandano foto ci si iscrive tutto il
giorno
ormai per me siete questo siete degli
amici siete parte della famiglia e mi
sveglio al mattino felice se leggo tutti
i vostri messaggi
se so che aspettato mio video è una roba
che ormai è naturale però riflettendoci
bene una cosa super speciale che non
capita tutti e quindi sono super
orgogliosa di tutto questo e vi
ringrazio tantissimo perché senza di voi
tutto questo non sarebbe mai successo
eccoci arrivati alla fine del video
spero che questo mio primo video ask vi
sia piaciuto
spero di aver risposto insomma alle
vostre domande alle vostre curiosità e
fatemi sapere qual è la domanda la
risposta anzi che mi ha colpito di più
commentando qui sotto se non avete
ancora fatto iscrivetevi al canale e
attivate la campanella vicino al tasso
di iscrizione per non perdere
nessunissimo dei miei video prossimi
chiaramente e ricordatevi anche di
seguirmi su tutti gli altri social
facebook intera e music hall vi mando un
bacione gambadoro alla prossima
[Musica]